all right everybody welcome to another
google hangout I'm excited to have
fellow youtuber John Mackay lean with me
he is uh he commented on some of my
videos and said hey we should do a
hangout together talking about how to
promote yourself on YouTube and so here
we are John welcome aboard man thanks
for having me it's a pleasure cool so I
mean obviously Meyer and says about me
tell them about what you're doing on
YouTube uh so i started youtube channel
about a a couple weeks ago I talked
about some of the things that I've
learned for us being an entrepreneur I I
started a series called daily motivation
like I kind of every morning I make
youtube video it's a one-take so there's
no it is I provide a motivation to get
my audience going and then the second
video every day I try to provide some
type of feedback or some type of
strategy to tell my artist become better
and smarter entrepreneurs cool so you
doing two videos a day yes cool man i'm
doing two videos a day too there you go
so your brand new you got each study
that what did you say last week the two
weeks ago sale- be calm so what you have
challenges you have questions what do
you want to talk about yeah I guess I
mean we both have the same audience or
similar audience so I guess we can kind
of talk about a growing girl how to grow
to youtube channel and then kind of
reaching out to new people or new uh new
subscribers cool i mean the the the
consistency definitely helped me there's
a lot of people who say uh you know you
shouldn't do two videos a day look at
what these other successful youtubers
are doing they're doing like three times
a week and I'm never I've never been one
to say hey look at what the average
person is doing so let's be that that
average guy right right that's that
that's the path to being average and I
think as long as you're producing
quality stuff like if you're producing
to quality videos a day that's not too
much if you're producing one crappy
video a month that is too much right as
long as it's good stuff people will pay
attention the watch will subscribe to
get to know you and that's definitely
helped my channel and we added almost 15
thousand subscribers last month uh and
now we just past sixty thousand
subscribers today or yesterday it's like
yeah I'm a pretty big growth for you
know the channels growing it's not it's
not a humongous channel yet but
percentage it's uh it's doing really
really well i think the consistency
really helps so it's like you don't keep
that up man keep doing your two Wieters
a day add tons of value make your really
good i had a hard time doing that myself
when i was doing to just myself I had a
hard time like doing one a week it was
I'm not a good editor I didn't know what
was in with the gear you know it took me
a long time to get used to it and then
once I hired this three people will help
me now but the first person was the
editor that was amazing because I can
give away all the stuff that I don't
like doing or most of it at least and
then focus on me being better in front
of the camera and doing more of those
videos and so it's really helped by
assuming you're doing everything
yourself for now but like something to
think about as you grow yeah no
definitely i use a choose like a little
a Sony action cam it's as kind of GoPro
cuz as the wide angle lens so on to
necessary worry about like my forehead
getting chopped off or something like
that so I mean it works for now and then
it's cool because I can actually upload
the videos from my phone since i'm not
home a lot so I mean it works for right
now and the iOS the audios previous in
the video calls / DS and so I mean it's
not too bad when I was starting I I
always did I went to costco to buy my
cameras because they had the best return
policy 98 written policy where others
like camera stores with seven days or 14
days and it's just not enough time to
test out a camera and see I hate
spending money till I'm making money so
I didn't want to go out and spend money
on the camera and then it wasn't what I
needed you know there's something wrong
with it whatever just didn't fit my
style so I burned through like four
different cameras at costco and then I
ended up with a sony because i had an
external mic jack and i use that for
about a year or two years before buying
a like a nice camera
at twenty-five hundred dollar camera so
baby steps along the way so how are you
so we're talking about promoting
yourself how why did you start this
channel you had success in business how
are you using YouTube or what's your
plan to use you to promote yourself uh
so I guess my my ultimate goal is to UM
is to kind of create a Content create
value for my audience and then you know
when they see when they see a lot of the
videos and if they like what I'm talking
about they can also check out my books
so I guess you can say that I might one
of my motives our YouTube channel is to
get or tell people about my books as
well so it's not just about creating
content and also one of the things i
learned that is that as an author it's
really good to have a youtube channel
because a a lot of a lot of people they
don't want just the books you know they
want for at first they want they want
some type of valid you want to see where
you're coming from they want to get an
idea of what you're going to talk about
or what they can expect from your book
so you know that's why i started youtube
channel is great and that way you know
like maybe create a video talk talk two
arguments about your book so yeah for me
uh i found that a lot of unexpected good
things come from my youtube channel i I
honestly started it without a huge
business model in mind it was just when
I was starting my business I struggled
so much and almost failed and quit and
then came back uh and you know I did I
didn't grow up with entrepreneur friends
or any kind of mentors or anything and
what saved me was learning from famous
entrepreneurs I looked up to I was in a
software company so that I looked at the
bill gates looked at how he started
Microsoft and apply those lessons and
that's what started helping my business
grow and because it was a visual learner
I was upset that you know the only good
stuff was it was in books and I didn't
enjoy reading as much as I enjoyed
consuming visual content so I thought
I'm just going to make stuff that I've
learned to help other people to try them
to try to help them not go through the
same suffering and crappy existence
that I had to go through who in building
my business and as a result uh a lot of
opportunities have come from it you know
I have a book deal with penguin Random
House I've gotten speaking opportunities
from around the world I get brand deals
with big companies who want me to go and
help them with some of the campaign's
they're working on most people think it
may be the only way to make money with
the YouTube channels through advertising
and Adsense and that's like the smallest
amount in terms of revenue streams you
can make from a youtube channel if you
build up an audience and doesn't have to
be a sizable audience just a targeted
audience you know so people want to
target this kind of person if that's
who's on your channel then there will be
companies who will pay you to help you
connect them to them so a lot of that
just came unexpectedly I started just to
add value just like I wish I had this
when I was becoming an entrepreneur and
that transformed them to be it's my
favorite platform I go to youtube first
I answer all my comments before I answer
Facebook and HootSuite for Twitter
there's a lot of fun I thinking you can
you can get obsessed with it you can get
obsessed with it and get a lot of value
out of it are you writing another book
where you've already written the books
so I've written two of them the first
one as a cost of I've got the second one
is an entrepreneur eat sheet and just
like you when I'm with my motive to
write that book was to kind of help
people who want to become entrepreneurs
or who are current entrepreneurs but
don't know where to start or what to
expect when they become entrepreneurs
and it takes you know like it takes away
like years of suffering and yours are
just confusion and it helps them save a
lot of money so I'm actually working on
third one as well the third one is uh
it's more towards retail sales since
I've been really successful retail sales
I kind of want to share my secret
knowledge I mean there's nothing secret
about it but it's just it's just
different techniques different things
that have helped me so I'm hoping to to
use that book to approach big-box
retailers and maybe
and or maybe have them user training
material maybe we can do seminars to
train ourselves associate and so forth
cool there's a question coming in from a
live view or Frank who's writing in hey
brother i found your channel today are
you doing hangouts every day I don't
know what your schedule is John I don't
do hang us every day I do them on
Thursdays I'm pretty anal about my
schedule to kind of keep track of
everything is going on and Thursdays my
what I call my public facing day so you
know I had to coffee meetings in the
morning I just had two interviews I'm
doing this anything that that is public
facing we're meeting people interviews
meetings hangouts calls i always do on
thursday so what I do with my youtube
channel is I'll have a morning video
that comes out I have a morning series
called in suppress oh that's kind of a
shot of entrepreneur motivation for the
morning the kick start your day and then
I have an afternoon typically it's a
wisdom you know ask Evan people ask me
questions and I get my responses on a
Thursday that I don't have that
afternoon video and instead through
hangouts um I find it's just a great way
to add some variety to the channel and
also get some interaction engagement
right like Frank you're watching live
you ask me a question here we are good
you know and my default that was anytime
somebody wants to talk to me they want
to interview me they want me to be
featured in some kind of thing I say hey
why don't we turn it into a google
hangout and I'll help promote you to my
audience as well and you know if I'm
doing the work of doing an interview
anyway why not make it into a video so
other people can learn and benefit from
it as well so today I have to hang outs
what just came back from one and now
this is the second one and then I'm off
to other meetings and then usually on
thursdays i have them set up so Frank
come back next Thursday otherwise it's
other good content on the channel for
you to enjoy John how much do you do
hangouts I have a story doing it yet
Chris one yeah why made a guide yeah the
chamber this is the first live hangout
that I've done on YouTube obviously I've
done other ones but they weren't live um
but yeah I mean I've been I've been
thinking about doing it once I think
once I start getting up
enough people interested in the channels
and I can kind of start um you know
doing interviews or you know think about
different things on how to use hangouts
into my youtube channel yeah it's
awesome um it's it's a great way to also
get some brand deals to you know i'm
working with sage they have accounting
software and they're doing a an event
coming up that i'm speaking at and to
help showcase the event I've been doing
a weekly hang out with somebody who is
speaking at the conference and getting
their take what are you gonna be talking
about how is that helpful for
entrepreneurs I think we can plug the
conference at the end and Frank was
watch on that one then we hopped over
this one too so he's going all in today
on the YouTube channel I'm starting one
with Aweber I don't know if you know a
weber they do email software and i'm
doing a monthly hang out with them where
I'm interviewing one of the people at
their team and it's not about hey is a
weber software great or not it's more
what lessons can we learn from your
business that can be applied to other
entrepreneurs and so it can be a great
way to not on promoting yourself but
also get paid right like brains are
paying me to do this to provide value to
entrepreneurs and was what I love doing
anyway so it works great Frank is
running back you're real good at this
bro I promise I will be here I love
Frank welcome aboard so Joe I think it
work for you too um what would help is
having a schedule like if people know
hey thursdays at two o'clock i'm going
to do a hangout then they'll come back
right anything you provide value to them
once they'll come back the next time
when the next time on the next time it's
slowly that audience builds i love just
be able to answer questions live i don't
know like a lot of the videos that i do
on my channel our QA like i'm answering
one person's question i talked for five
or six minutes on it but i can't get to
everybody's question because it's i
don't have that many slots murdered in
two videos a day you know there's
hundreds of questions i'm throwing away
but the live ones i look just like
seeing interaction and i don't know i
think it makes people feel a little more
connected to you and having variety so
like somerset videos some are famous
entrepreneur videos some are live
hangouts i think people like that
variety and helps you show different
sides of
you so I'd encourage it man I'd
encourage it no definitely I'm
definitely into it okay livestream I'm
glad I'm glad you pop the cherry here
today Evan Carmichael channel I like it
it's going to happen a lot of people
never used it before and I gotta walk
them through that the last one we had
the guys camera wasn't working and so we
were just doing audio only so there's
still some tech issues around it but but
I'm a big fan I'm a big fan of the
hangouts and talk about promoting
yourself I'm put on your book this is
that something like your work on
promoting your books I'm in the process
of writing the book I'm working with a
publisher so there's much longer time
lines on it right like I have to get the
book done October by the end of October
this year and then it won't come out
until next September so that's a like
when you self-publish you decide when it
gets published when you look at the
publisher there's more time and people
been asking me for years when you're
going to write a book and what I've done
is I now have a weekly series about my
book writing process so every week I
have a lesson that I share and it's this
stuff is super ghetto like you should my
videos are I have a cameraman where we
shoot with nice quality I'm miked up
this one is kind of get aware I'm just
shooting off my mac and I have a
microphone here using the Yeti
microphone but the other one the book
one is it's just ipad i am walking with
my ipad out like this walking down my
street and i have some lesson that I
want to share and some update on the
book and then I asked a answer people's
questions about the book so people ask
me questions about what I'm writing or
about the process or they want to write
a book me with my advice and so they
don't answer their questions and what it
helps do is it helps keep momentum
around the book without me plug in the
book all the time right without me
saying so everybody watching you got to
make sure you buy my book because it's
fantastic right so I'm jittering
curiosity I'm general interest and even
right now Frank is asking me what's name
or your book right so we got I can't
tell you Frank it's a it's private for
now it's not my decision but having a
series about it helps you plug it
constantly helps generate interest and
awareness and you can still provide tons
of value in those videos without you
selling anything right like you're
selling without selling you're selling
by providing value and curiosity and
general momentum so that that weekly
series really helps and and you know for
you if you're putting promoting an
existing book you could take concepts
that you talk about in the book each
chapter and turn that into a weekly
video and then take questions and answer
in so every week you're talking about
the book but you're not selling it
you're you're promoting it in a
value-add way and that gets people
interested and excited I think it's a
fantastic way to promote a book and
really any project that you're working
on share the journey like if you're
writing a new book share that journey if
you are launching a new website if
you're building a new product you
created a new info product whatever it
is don't just share once you've released
it share the process of making it and
the challenges you're going through and
the lessons that you've learned and some
of the ideas that you're excited about
because that gets people excited for
them when you release it they already
know what it's all about they can't wait
to see it so I encourage anybody who's
trying to create a YouTube channel don't
just use it to promote your stuff but to
add value and share the journey that
you're going on right now I definitely
agree with are you writing another book
are you doing what new project are you
up to yeah I was um like I mentioned
early i was writing a third book on
retail sales and i might do a fourth one
um that's kind of like a it well it's
not really a story but um it's kind of
it'll be written in like a suspect
suspense fiction novel kind of about
immigrants coming to us to chase the
american dream of being entrepreneurs um
so that i'm very excited about because
um it's i'm taking a different approach
on that book that i've taken with the
first three it's going to be a challenge
but i think people going to love that
one that's cool man that you could
definitely do a weekly story on that
right like as you're writing a book or
you could talk about your story like are
you an immigrant are your parents
immigrants you know there's something
that made you want to write this book
for immigrants write something that like
pounds here right so you can tell that
story in a couple different ways you can
have people share their stories I Kate
tell me your story about you immigrating
to the country or your parents
immigrated in the country or for people
who want to immigrate to the contrary
people living in other countries oh hey
I want to move to the US and here's my
story or questions about it that could
be a cool series to kind of follow you
along your journey as you write the book
and then once it's out how are you
marking how you promoting it right where
are you going to publish it what
software using to design it you know are
you doing everything yourself are using
external people now all of that could be
each video could be its own individual
plug talking about a specific topic then
answering people's questions and every
week you're talking about the book and
showcase in a building momentum without
ever having to go on and sell anything
no I like the idea because a lot of
people they don't excuse me they like
the fact that um or dinner like whenever
you come out of nowhere and just kind of
throw something on like hey go buyers
right now so I don't like the fact that
you're making weekly videos because it
kind of builds up to that it builds up
there uh um well it builds up their dads
patients so whenever Sousa comes out
they're gonna be asking you like was
coming out was coming out let me know
and then so i'll buy rather than saying
oh hey go by the book right now you know
a lot of people don't like that yeah I
mean I guess some people are okay with
the hard sale I hate it personally like
I never respond to that when I hear
somebody doing that I never respond well
to it so I don't want to be that guy
who's then doing it to other people I
don't respond to it right and I think by
constantly adding value to people so as
an example a lot of brands approached me
big companies will approach me and say
hey we love your audience can you
promote our new computer or are
software or new resource whatever i only
talk about things i actually use in like
right I never get on and make you betta
say you need to go by the newest this
spicy right cuz it feels sleazy and I'd
also lose my audience right like if
that's all I was talking about people
would would leave and so whenever I'm
recommending a product or service most
of them not getting paid for it but if I
am it's because I I use it like I'm
telling my story of how i use it and how
it's helpful and that authenticity helps
bring people in and trust you and most
of the stuff I do with brands I tell
them I'm not just I'm not going to
promote your like this is not a sales
pitch so I'm happy to talk to plug
something at the end right but if I'm
talking about the sage summit that's
coming up right this event with say gee
I'm speaking at I'm not just going to go
and promote how great it is I'm having
the speakers come on and talk about what
they're going to share right adding
value having a discussion just like here
like work I'm gonna we're going to
unplugging you write like you are in the
description of this channel people who
are watching you want to learn about
with John it's in the description we're
plugging his channel but it's not saying
john is a king john you gotta go check n
values amazing you know we're having
about we're having a discussion we're
trying to add value and I think that
authenticity really helps engender a
loyal audience which will help you be
able to do whatever sell books sell you
know spotlights so product review sell
brand deals whatever you want to do with
it no absolutely on one of the things I
always stressed entrepreneurs is that
you know building a social media
following is just super important
because like let's say um if you have a
product at the moment um and then you
you promoted to them well not it
succeeds you can always come back and
let them know about about future
products and that's why I creating value
to them is so important um you have to
create value to first attract that
audience and you know it's uh and that
way you kind of a tell them about your
products um or let them know over the
course of like maybe four or five years
or you know however you decide how long
you decide to have them so questions
coming in from Michael who's why
alive I have a question rely on being
entrepreneur so badly but what stopping
me is I'm different I'm blind in my left
eye and face challenges in life due to
my poor vision I'm just afraid people
want to accept me for who I am my family
friends told me I won't be able to be
successful in my life I want to be the
best I can be proved them wrong what
advice can you give me uh so first of
all there's tons of blind entrepreneurs
who are successful and I think the
biggest challenge and you know John can
adjust it to but I think the biggest
challenge for me is your environment
sucks right like your friends and your
family suck and that that that that's a
lot of people write a lot of people
don't have supportive family don't have
supportive friends tell them i call this
heap with a little man the people who
hold back your dreams the people who
they're so afraid to take their own shot
at something great that instead of doing
something amazing with their life they
just throw tomatoes at you and say you
can't do anything and that's a huge
challenge and you know you can't change
your parents your parents are your
parents but you can change your friends
you can change your environment and your
environment is the videos you watch like
you're watching this you might get
inspired right and let me give you a
little bit more confidence that
shouldn't just be once at three o'clock
in the afternoon on a Thursday right
that should be every day you want to
start your day with something that gives
you energy excitement helps you be great
right what TV shows do you watch what
books do you read what's on your what's
in your environment right like what's on
your wall right what what statues do you
have right what gets you excited this
all has meaning to me that gets me
excited in the day what do you wear
right all of that stuff is important and
if you look at your environment it
probably sucks the people in your life
suck your environment sucks you can't
create great things if your environment
isn't great so that would be my first
step I used to think I was too young I
had a software company was 19 years old
I thought it was too young to sell to
these big guys and it wasn't until I
broke out of that and said hey I'm I
can't you add value to them didn't care
didn't care how young I was as long as I
could help them it's never been easier
to be an entrepreneur it's ever been
easier to be successful and Sophie oh
I'd look at I would look up more
successful blind entrepreneur
is that you can relate to and may be
totally blind like you're blind in one
eye look at me we're totally blind who
have a successful business and read
their stories every day and watch your
videos every day and put them up on your
wall and create a routine that supports
you because once you change that
environment you once you start believing
that you can be great that's when great
things start to happen no I definitely
agree on I tattoo your point I am I
always tell myself and other
entrepreneurs if you can't strive in the
environment you're right you're in right
now definitely change it put yourself in
an environment where you can strive and
succeed and also another thing is that I
love it when people tell me I can't do
something because I just want to prove
them wrong so bad I mean em all sooner
or later but I me I just just use that
as motivation you know people who are
telling you you can do it prove them
wrong you know because sooner or later
you're going to be able to do it you're
going to be able to um you know kind of
show Mike hey I've done it you know you
were wrong um mmm it's not matter being
right or wrong it's just showing them
that you're better than that you're
better than the person they made you out
to be um so definitely keep pushing find
out where your passion is and you know
just just execute keep working out every
day it's not a it's not a sprint it's a
marathon just you know just do a little
by little every day and it's before you
know what you're already up there yeah I
love it and I was thinking of another
point to add but I got lost so it
happens to um I think one last question
coming in from Vic cv Vic's Eve I I
always get told i have a great
personality and should have more
subscribers unfortunate doesn't grow I
did try searchable content but it
doesn't work what can i do to be
discovered thank you for your hangout
seven they're awesome uh so it is a
challenge right and and with my channel
my growth started really slow and then
it it started taking off and it was a
function of two things one me getting
better like I thought I was good but if
you look back on my old videos I'm Way
better now not just the production
quality not just the audio in the zoom
in the editing that kind of stuff
but me like me on camera I am better
than I was way before and so you can
practice and you can get better and you
can model success you could look at
youtubers that you look up to and
speakers you look up to whether it's
tony robbins or less brown or brunei
brown or whoever it is learn from them
and improve yourself the other thing
that i found immensely helpful is doing
collaborations right just like this
right this is a collaboration we are we
are living what we say right so you have
you guys like what John has to say here
you're gonna check out his channel
you're going to go to his website is in
the description go check it out if you
like John right so I did a bunch of
collaboration with other youtubers where
I shared my message of believe some of
them were youtube entrepreneur some of
the more makeup entrepreneur some of the
more young entrepreneurs right as long
as an entrepreneur you can benefit from
my channel so was partnering up with
other youtubers and doing a
collaboration video I do one for them
they do one for me and I brought a lot
more audience on board the trick i found
really what that was every time my video
went on their page uh i would comment on
every comment every comment that they
got i would think that would say thank
you so much for the great feedback or if
they had a problem with it i I'd write
back to them and I still do this video's
that I've released like a year ago that
I still check once a month to see if
there's any new comment just to thank
them or to interact with them because of
those people watch the video and liked
it and then they see a response for the
person who created it their way more
likely to then go will check out my
channel and subscribe and if you're
producing good stuff then I'm more
likely to stay on board stay on track
and keep following up anything quick on
that mic um John what my know uh it's uh
no you're absolutely right because um
one or one of the things that I wanted
to add it was on you sure she needed to
advantage on like her ass your your
friends on Facebook to go subscribe to
your channel because I know a lot of
people do that but one of the good ways
is to use Twitter on if you have it sign
of HootSuite HootSuite is um is really
good especially user with Twitter
because you can actually schedule posts
in advance
so like let's say for making videos um
you can actually have have a different
video linked with every hour every half
an hour Oh however and I think just um
that that's another way or that's
another channel to get your videos out
there um get exposure because people
want if you use the right hash tags
people are going to see those your
tweets about the videos are gonna go
check it out and you need more views you
can get more subscribers and it's
eventually going to lead to more growth
yeah Mike Mike my path has always been
through quality of the content and less
focusing on the titles and his
description in the time like still
important to do it the discoverability
but you could have the best optimize
title the best description the best tag
but if your content isn't good enough
then as soon as YouTube ranks you and
you get some views and your watch time
is down like look at how many people are
actually watching your stuff how long do
they stick around because if it's
dropping off then you're going to fall
out of YouTube's search results I
remember what I wanted to say before I
made this clip I found this clip that
made me think of you some Sylvester
Stallone and i put it up on my channel
uh two weeks ago june twenty third so
just over just over a week ago and it's
no means yes and it goes i love hearing
no cuz no Jin's just means yes you know
the way he says it is great and he just
loves being told no because that means
he's going to get that guy he's going to
prove him wrong he's gonna make it come
around he's gonna turn it around um cool
well we're up against a clock it's
already three I gotta go through an
interview John thank you for the time
man everybody watching thank you i know
we didn't get all the questions but next
hangout and you can check out john's
info in the link below thanks everyone
thanks Erin